[Musica]
[Applauso]
questa immagine che ci rappresenta lo
sviluppo sostenibile
in realtà ci nasconde un grande inganno
scopriamo insieme quali
se noi aumentiamo la produzione andiamo
a consumare più risorse naturali e
queste risorse naturali non sono
infinite sono illimitate sono limitate e
un altro fattore che incide
negativamente sulla sostenibilità
ambientale e che la popolazione mondiale
sta continuando ad aumentare
pensate che negli ultimi 100 anni siamo
passati da un miliardo a circa 8
miliardi di persone
qual è la soluzione per risolvere il
problema della sostenibilità ambientale
possono essere solo due non smettiamo di
crescere economicamente per non
consumare più risorse naturali non
smettiamo di nascere per non consumare
più risorse a lavorare
per trovare una terza soluzione dobbiamo
prima risolvere il nostro rebus quali
inganno nasconde questa immagine
link anno che nasconde e che l'economia
non è un valore
l'economia un mezzo per creare valore
all women l'ambiente è quello di cui
vorrei parlare oggi di un nuovo modello
di sviluppo che separa l'economia del
denaro dall'economia del benessere
un modello capace di vincolare lo
sviluppo economico alla sostenibilità
ambientale e al benessere sociale
un modello capace di riaffermare i
principi democratici e il diritto
all'autodeterminazione
un modello che considera il denaro non
come uno strumento di coercizione ma
come un mezzo di coesione
un modello quindi capace di favorire la
crescita economica ma in maniera
sostenibile
facciamo un esempio pratico provate ad
immaginare una comunità che definisce le
caratteristiche del latte e che si
impegna ad acquistarlo i produttori del
latte inizieranno per accedere a questo
mercato inizieranno a produrlo secondo
quelle caratteristiche
adesso provate ad immaginare che queste
caratteristiche del latte non siano solo
riferite al prodotto ma contengono anche
i criteri che l'azienda deve rispettare
per dimostrare quanto sia sostenibile
ecco quello che abbiamo che vi ho appena
descritto è un ambiente dove le regole
della competitività non sono più legate
al denaro fine a se stesso ma sono
legata la capacità di creare valore
all'uomo e all'ambiente
ora l'idea di separare l'economia del
denaro dall'economia del benessere non è
ciò che caratterizza il nostro modello
di sviluppo
pensate che il primo a parlarne fu
aristotele ma è come questo si diffonde
nel mondo
e quello che noi abbiamo fatto e
utilizzare le tecnologie più innovative
quelle ad esempio l'intelligenza
artificiale la block chain per
digitalizzare il nostro modello
è quello che abbiamo ottenuto è un
sistema di sviluppo completamente in
troverà interoperabile e decentralizzato
capace di svilupparsi dal basso
attraverso la condivisione la
moltiplicazione del valore
questo sistema di sviluppo lo dovete
vedere come un grande ambiente virtuale
dove domanda e offerta si incontrano per
realizzare obiettivi comuni
e quello che vi ho appena raccontato è
un grande cambio di paradigma
quello che obbligherà oggi e in futuro
a considerare le aziende non far operare
l'azienda non più come il sistema chiuso
ma all'interno di sistemi dinamici
aperti
per capire
il concetto di sistema dinamico aperto
dobbiamo prima capire come funziona il
nostro sistema di sviluppo
quando l'insieme di imprese aziende o
enti del terzo settore iniziano a
collaborare e cooperare ha di fatto
iniziato a scambiare informazioni
dati relazioni e conoscenze
il nostro sistema di sviluppo non fa
altro che registrare questi beni
intangibili
elaborarli secondo un approccio olistico
e ridistribuire questo valore
all'interno così sistema produttivo per
valorizzarli
per comprendere il concetto di bene
intangibile come possiamo far
riferimento a facebook il valore di
facebook sono i dati sono gli utenti
registrati
nella sulla piattaforma e questi udenti
e producono ricavi ad esempio le imprese
che vogliono avere visibilità per
promuovere i propri prodotti ai partiti
per influenzare l'opinione pubblica i
beni intangibili del nostro sistema di
sviluppo sono la proprietà intellettuale
del modello che nasce con il preciso
statuario di renderla accessibile a
tutti e gratis il capitale relazionale
che l'insieme delle relazioni
che aderiscono a questo circuito
il capitale umano che l'insieme delle
conoscenze integrate dell'interno col
sistema produttivo ed infine il capitale
organizzativo che l'insieme degli
strumenti e delle applicazioni software
e che vanno a costituire il nostro
sistema di sviluppo
ora questo sistema sinergico integrato
di bene intangibile va a costituire il
nostro capitale intellettuale
in questo capitale intellettuale viene
trasferito da un operatore all'altro e
così facendo cresce esponenzialmente nel
tempo
pensate che noi attraverso questo
modello questo sistema di sviluppo
questo capitale intellettuale
siamo riusciti in pochi anni a
sottoscrivere circa 2.000 accordi di
partnership in 74 paesi essere diversi
abbiamo generato opportunità commerciali
circa 1500 in 84 nazioni diverse
adesso vediamo come questo capitale
intellettuale è in grado di valorizzare
la vostra attività economica o sociale
e la prima necessità che andiamo a
soddisfare e quella di generare delle
concrete opportunità d'affari anche
verificando eventuali sinergie rapporti
di collaborazione con tutti i partner
aderenti a questo circuito
e questo può avvenire
applicando un sistema relazionale non
gerarchico che l'evoluzione degli
attuali sistemi di network marketing
ed è quello che vi permetterà di
accedere a questo network internazionale
senza nessun livello di intermediazione
la seconda necessità che andiamo a
soddisfare e quella di pianificare le
strategie aziendali per gestire
mediamente o nel caso di un ente
pubblico di pianificare le strategie
territoriali anche al fine di
valorizzare il proprio patrimonio
ambientale e culturale
attraverso il nostro sistema questo
permette di far operare
di prendere tutti gli operatori
economici di un territorio e farli
partecipare in maniera attiva e
propositiva allo sviluppo di un
programma di lungo periodo passato
esclusivamente su criteri di
sostenibilità ambientale e sociale
questo permette al nostro sistema non
solo di dire cosa fare ma in tempo reale
anche con chi e dove
una volta che sappiamo cosa fare
dobbiamo acquisire le competenze per
realizzare i nostri obiettivi
è quello che il nostro sistema di
sviluppo offre e la possibilità di
applicare all'interno della vostra
azienda
un nuovo modello organizzativo e
gestionale
capace di trasformare le catene del
valore in ecosistemi di servizi
integrati ad alto valore aggiunto
ti spieghiamo in termini semplici
capisco che sono cose complesse
è come aprire una porta all'interno del
vostro ufficio dalla quale poter
acquisire le conoscenze per valorizzare
le vostre risorse umane o
accedere a un insieme di servizi che vi
offrirà un incubatore produttivo
virtuale
arrivata a questo punto siamo pronti per
gestire questo grande processo di
trasformazione digitale e quello che
offre il sistema e la possibilità di
adottare delle piattaforme tecnologiche
integrate
capace di applicare le innovazioni di
prodotto e di processo e questo non solo
per produrre in maniera sostenibile ma
anche per creare un rapporto di fiducia
con il consumatore con il vostro cliente
il quale potrà entrare virtualmente
nella vostra azienda
passo successivo è quello di cooperare
con le altre aziende per ricostruire
nuove filiere produttive e distributive
completamente eco sostenibile
quando noi sentiamo parlare di consorzio
di cooperative molta gente scappa a
gambe levate
ma quello che dobbiamo
sapere quello che dobbiamo ricordare che
questi strumenti in passato hanno fatto
dell'italia un grande paese e quindi il
problema non è lo strumento
ma il fatto di aver delegato a delle
persone che non hanno aspettato di
mangiare il frutto dopo aver seminato la
pianta ma si sono mangiati direttamente
il seme
è quello che noi abbiamo progettato sono
delle piattaforme tecnologiche
decentralizzate capaci di cogliere ogni
aspetto positivo della cooperazione
senza dover delegare nessuno
l'ultimo anello del nostro sistema di
sviluppo e quello che vi permetterà di
avere visibilità all'interno del nostro
marketplace
adesso pensate a google youtube facebook
pensate che questi strumenti invece di
dare visibilità
alle aziende che pagano in denaro danno
visibilità alle aziende più sostenibili
ecco noi siamo riusciti a vincere questa
grande sfida
abbiamo replicato tutti questi strumenti
e gli abbiamo applicato un processo di
certificazione del valore il quale non
solo regola la visibilità ma anche le
priorità degli investimenti
ma non solo
utilizzare tecnologie proprietarie
significa operare senza cedere dati a
terzi
e quello che dovete capire del
cambiamento e che in futuro non sarà il
denaro ad avere valore ma l'informazione
bene io
diciamo ho terminato la parte più
semplice del mio discorso
[Risate]
adesso ho bisogno di tutta la vostra
attenzione
la domanda che ci dobbiamo porre è se la
tecnologia potrà mai
determinare il nostro destino
e la risposta è no
tornando al nostro sistema relazionale
questo non l'abbiamo solo progettato per
gestire i rapporti di collaborazione
all'interno di un eco sistema produttivo
ma l'abbiamo progettato per gestire
l'informazione per formare l'individuo
sul piano intellettuale e morale
il nostro obiettivo è quindi quello di
utilizzare le tecnologie per dare vita
ad un nuovo umanesimo digitale
il nostro modello è una filosofia
pratica che ha come obiettivo il
recupero dell'individuo
dell'uomo inteso come persona
un individuo che si realizza attraverso
il proprio progetto di natura
e per realizzare questo progetto di
natura
noi dobbiamo evolverci come collettività
verso una nuova coscienza collettiva che
rimetta l'uomo e l'ambiente al centro
io sono convinto che dall'italia partirà
un nuovo rinascimento
l'italia ancora una volta dimostrerà
quanto la sua cultura possa essere di
riferimento per il mondo intero
perché non c'è cambiamento senza un
nuovo rinascimento
[Applauso]
[Musica]